This
is the cowl N.E.H. American English dialect recordings
collection produced with funding from the National Endowment for the Humanities and the Center
for Applied Linguistics. This is tape number
sixteen
the
another not isn't it in there what about about a monitor all right about about about a do good isn't it a lot of
it already committed a long long time the bottom of the modern for a while about
about a ball and there are holes in the bottom of them all out of all the holes
and available to the ball I'm
Mark I'm going to have all that about about a boy they have all bothered about a notable
and gave all balls into the ball whole America to get hold of the devoted notable Great Britain
and
Ireland been able to devote a lot already reason to read every vote of all America today
all going to vote a vote of the boy and there are the navel of all going to vote out of all
like four o'clock and a ball goes into a vote of all Amber All in all those unable to vote a vote of
approval act and they've all been to build a vote of all N.B.A. all their people to go to the get the ball
that brought their name although they did vote to build a little amber out of the naval though they devoted
already every degree and they all how about that about a vote a vote of give all day go now to the liberated
reacted the navel rain a reason to read a lot of my God although that about about a greater degree to
do to do to get about about about about effective and I'm delighted Laurie David is going to continue to give out
about about it a lot on day one one was a bit about a monologue large break a day every
two days and if you didn't get about him
onto. Well.
There are one of them and I have nearly three and I have three generating myself.
To get your on the.
Very same day.
That's Sunday taking you and I to tune in a matter of
the
nearly
five hundred a
same as editor but added nearly noon easy to
read
seventy one
days.
They all
say
that
they
say
they. I
am I on the
right
side
the the way
I found here what companies are in Congress.
Well will take him down the right leg of
my lap a
lot
and America
Imperial akes board and the gym
right now in the land. No fight for this fight for the backup. That is
accompanied by the fight for the background and then there's a company
by my name of or good by the name of Jesus
to get it down again you know why he is
a failed brain to
universalise universalise a real big company and they break it down
now B.G.P. dealer in Henderson but it's still universalise And
but I guess I'll just find the
truth and they break it down and try to write for the
vice president as a part of their broke the back
office of the white mining
company and another mark in another bill by another
name for them but it still all belongs to the same thing
with again that it take it rational
read or well not a left wing
like a court used to be at its core a lose its like they all make for the right but
they brought out Brown and Williamson which used to be a really big stuff. And
so now they buy the Brown and
Williamson and old so predictable. Now I am period until the
Buy from his grandparents. But an hour an LP deep
and and they don't manage back in this country ever been
in the back of a crowd if you had quit after the going.
And yes it was excellent and had weeks to have emotion A with neighbors but
Sam landed here. And there he was yeah I don't know that
felt maybe the for the him why he would not he was not a followed
by example by the by
the American the rails father was another would he go by the Slocum lonesome.
Reynolds you know advertisers camelback amount by Sam on the sea and whenever Randall got one he
said well come out and the fields and they really admire
and just feels love the most they satisfy and need nothing they satisfy the ticket
market and I said
I know it well as that's the little packs in the for him to just
put on a show in the old days
when I was going to be that old and just if there was a somebody coming to have
an audience that was always up for all these
policies about and he had time to do that we don't have time and when you
come here. What you know now they only say shit to the coins and jacket
on down the line like an old Miss Eloise go roaming the Amanda
Bynes Rosie say Mama Pope I
saw this on my own I
really appear to know that was a friend of mine big
rigs like you Bill was wanted you to hear on the radio they were there when
they were high right
now
as a and had
retired and they had a square room that
was independent and I think I prefer a first. It was lucky to see the one there and they
would punish you cigarettes. Just to get you to smoke your family's jail. That's
what the
sound of it.
The
the
brow the over the stomach must never get
so servers around the world the right to drink and I don't now but I used
to get the girl from nowhere near Tacoma to get me a black girl about
the sizes too small to back down there that over that family
I'm like you know your skin color or we were on the
bus that as the right to get that they've had enough of the one day that they
did seize the moment a great wrong to reach down a better
feeling. Please give me a good girl another says that that they had actually the
present danger and I can doubt the mother a vet. I mean you have that it with a win because my
the Jets
were blue but I do I left as a one on the California
pagan hope you can dispatch and feels so good to see something the back in
your head against the.
Want.
Jackie.
LOL
I we get them
you place ready
to
go there they go back to square. They got the balls man over them and then
my eyes on that is the back seat made a good bye.
If it the very right it was good as that by then they said but then it
make make
them in their favor the right whether they go then the next day coming
give them the chance this day don't miss power. Don't think Great. There are a great series out
that leg of the body and there was everybody seems
to it. They never showed you just the sign you just see aside my expression is
if you see me
with that my Sunday clothes on and the when to drag me an accident when
it comes down you don't see the Getting see. Is on the inside of my lips fascinated in
other words it's just sort of like cows and and goats sashimi their
service bad of the
past think it's a look back and let the doing
greener alone aside in gilts is terrible but they will get
out just the just the
means
they know well the.
Yeah well the in and out all that you see a fight for there's a right good side Martin they got a lot
of how you take a little market for this got no plants in the know
nothing the second either is or they got the name so I could not it was a clever they're called such
bitches the relentless market is Mark. But the most of the circuit writers we have here. Might
come second not us out of the plant we have more options than it would
have to go in their carts and isn't this a little warm there
Mark with the
rise of the good hope the sudden rise we have
here is a big bore if you're in the plants here. Now then they have
second riders were
willing to
come right here. So I get
that like circuit breaker. You know to make
them that good man good good and maintain a precarious they had to come back and then
and did you know the film the
the people that may be legal to
gether didn't have a circular right of a man and
they must avoid that they want to get in
there and live together and maybe sometimes when the first settlement
was a gift that I hated and waited till somebody come around a man
and had a
change that you don't need this creature like that even if
you was outed yourself
as the chairman.
I'm trying to well anything out of the ordinary is a
big thing that's not natural
is and cause the best way to be of course now they've been doing their fingers
now whole lot more so than the you stick with the user thing but any
esteem it's
not natural environment and I told I'd so produce and so livestock.
I don't like it is well because the owners are back in
market if they do or they
don't know it's the his to He who hesitates as
well until he gets going but anything out of the
ordinary is a big and
overweight and I have a few times a man has a he's got to set himself on
the back
quickly and man am screwed around scrag me several times.
Yeah by him that is a lie it's been said
that it is easy death it's in the oven says I he said because he could enjoy the good
scratch but then in a house that they keep the ice
to the sail. Don't pat no feet no wiggle no playing good play
anything anything it's at right now as far as I'm
concerned by what I'm going to Andrew they don't there's no use to
and he come down with this hand stuck right in his side. I mean that means as long as
he keeps that hand to his side right he's been there.
So I think you're on your mind
about whether I'll go now to get along or she'll talk to me
I don't give a darn if I have another club. I get on Nov I should check
you know she told him no and have no doubt that I will miss the fact
she want to know and she want to know the
difference sign that said. Anything that's not natural is a B.S. man can stick this thing
that is that he's
being that mean anything is. No No another
word Jimmy is saying about holding his hand like that's normal but many times in things that's
fine thanks and it's a fact that
the
public now that the long
line know that give
us a lot of fun. Yes they want our space which every day close to
see and other words if he were
a
star if you started the event coming
to an end landlady Michu is just so that's another
thing I like to go down it means I give you six tunes that you have to ring go away
and that's two or seven that's three zero eight of that's four
now that's
five zero that any of the numbers want to
be opposed to in other words Mr Moore Mr Moti talks going to sixty eight cents in the file
again is this what he mean he was jumping you to say they believe they have the other stuff but
if he started it with sixty
three and he took it that met with the difficulty get back down to sixty
six just as water was up and it closed because there was a lot
of times. Most of the sun was not knightly much so used to
start one of
their businesses and the buyer will do that and say I'll give you
sixty and but he means he was a fool in the other five.
But when he done that he means he'd stand that at the end but
he wants it's a little bind the other way to the other black belt of our weight debt and you come
back to his sixty eight which you don't do because you've already got the
financing and they
just did come out of the now you're the only downside.
I'm going down
can be taken I can get the good market. Steve
is receiving the full.
And he hit it will knock out it saving it for export growth both that when it is a newborn
agreed it takes
a vet so the border with this by the back of me isn't a
plant thirty years ago. That's great
and that's the grain Yes big countersink in the grain of
it but now the thing is to get market. Somebody's got an argument that they could
market one day and just say he says no I am right.
He says I'm right and he says when I use it you don't make a mistake
he says no. I don't make any
mistakes because he was just raving and he was getting his coffee.
He says that if you got a deed so you have said Jim said yes that it's
in right name and he's dead man's That is this well now you've got a tenant of the
automobile have existed and said it's in writing and stays in right and
said where the due to the house is
right at Tyler that automobile right and says whatever
I put it on took is in right now so I'm band of the right to call you they've been
dragging Israel because it's a magnet for a band that was just a pawn and that they it is
then this a is there was this is this is now that the Elmo live and that
takes bowling alley. Let
me know it's a little bit of
a but
just thing in other words if that fixes were to say that ticket would a get lost down the back
as that is bound to hang up someone is going to say it's come this big you devil they got
busy could get there
and
he.